il dirigerait je regardais la les
chiffres j'analyse un petit peu les
enquêtes d'opinion sur l'émission j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya vraiment une
dimension qui manque c'est la dimension
reality show il y en a pas du tout c'est
quelque chose qui marche très bien en ce
moment qui est assez à la mode - j'ai
l'impression qu'il faudrait que vous un
style y ait un petit peu de reality show
si c'est possible en mission ça c'est
pas les gens de s'y met de temps à autre
vers moi moi il suffirait que je
surveille la courbe d'audience et puis
dès que je vois que ça retombe nous
fasse un petit signe que vous basculez
un petit peu comme ça dans ce cas c'est
même un peu sordide c'est mon exposé
question réalité chaud voila voila je
crois que c'est clair mais c'est comme
enjeu la règle c'est ce que j'étais en
train de me dire il faut que les
téléspectateurs ne se rende compte de
rien il faudra qu'on vienne d'un petit
signal tout bêta geste de la main oui ou
coujoux
fredonne quelque chose je pense hélas ou
connaissez la chanson déroutement vers
de silva voilà presque l'oeil ouvre dès
le début c'est aujourd'hui dimanche de
la fuite est venue d'un coup de tonnerre
voyez moi je parle ce sont les travaux
commencent à poser des questions peut
pas rendre un juste comme ça veut
simplement génial c'est aujourd'hui des
mois récents ça va président organise un
président professeur ça marche bien vos
adhérents là l'audience ma merci un pays
vous aide un pay cette histoire en même
temps vous s'amène parce que moi j'ai eu
deux cent mille nouveaux adhérents dans
la semaine et ses doigts me disais à
l'instant je lui dis c'est un boulot
incroyable
et à ce propos la ce qui serait bien
c'est qu'il ya un moment dans l'émission
où je puisse replacer les trois
revendications principales oui la mtf et
redire de temps de vous engager dans les
caméras ne tournent pas tant d'être
génial ça va mais en même temps je me
dis il faut répéter les choses que sinon
on n'arrive jamais ben voilà même truc
sur la commencer j'aimerais ça va
commencer à trouver comment se fait
poser ça quelque part peut-être cet
homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
saper et conserver son argument les
prêts à tout tous les moyens sont bons
même la qualité
[Musique]
à
là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nick samson gloria lasso maritime et
gilbert carpentier patrick chesnais
ans prennent le professeur rollin le
président lorrain le chien ap et moi
[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir bienvenue au studio
bonaparte pour hardy matt je vous
interromps il y a un petit problème pour
l'émission de ce soir je vous dis tout
de suite c'est de ma faute
la semaine dernière samedi dernier vous
avez dit je m'en branle
vous vous en souvenez grossièreté que
j'ai été obligé de sanctionner puisque
sa mission de service public par un
extrait du documentaire culturel veut ni
cité des doges
mais et c'est là mon erreur je vous en
ai mis 13 secondes en me fiant aux
barèmes 92 j'avais eu les yeux
or j'ai reçu entre temps le barème 93
qui lui est de 15 secondes pour allemand
branle
il ya par conséquent un reliquat de deux
secondes de venise qu'il faudra diffusé
à un moment ou un autre de l'émission
c'est comme vous voulez vais je préfère
prendre la punition tout de suite à ce
moment-là professeurs comme ça on en
sera débarrassé
alors allons-y allons vite je vais aller
planter sur un quai moussu voilà
maintenant que la faute est
intégralement réparer nous pouvons
enchaîné avec le petit bilan qui est
désormais de tradition dans cette
émission
la séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence
consacrée à rebbie jackson et sa thierry
c'était votre idée est là vraiment en
huit semaines 8 idée géniale réellement
on peut dire que vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle un magicien de la télévision ça
valait bien ces quelques
applaudissements et puis en même temps
cette semaine tout magicien que vous
êtes airs et j'ai bien peur que vous ne
parveniez plus à trouver une idée
du même tonneau détrompez-vous
professeur j'ai trouvé allons les
chapeaux jackson chapeau belge légal
mais excusez moi thierry faisant discret
mais comment vous est venue cette idée
géniale je te restaurant avec ma femme
est le voeu que vous mangez l'équation
du saumon fumé professeurs et le patron
du resto porter une petite chéchia
chéchia chapeau aux charrues jackson
c'est comme ça que j'ai trouvé associé
chapeau
j'ai trouvé tout de suite aux propos
jackson génial que je crois qu'il n'y a
plus qu'à regarder la séquence
voici les chapeaux jackson ah non pardon
professeur j'ai fait une petite erreur
là tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que
c'étaient des du saumon fumé
oui en fait le saumon fumé avec ma femme
c'était la veille un jour des chapeaux
jackson et de lâcher cia's c'était
plutôt du côté de gagnoa
aussi voici les chapeaux jackson
personnes chapelier de père en fils
depuis 1867 fête cette année un triple
anniversaire les 90 ans de la fondation
de la firme le 50e anniversaire de sa
succursale 70 boulevard adolphe max et
les 60 ans d'existence de la maison-mère
157 boulevard anspach entre la bourse et
la place fontainas jackson nous y
présente dans un cadre entièrement
rénové les premières marques de chapeau
de magnifiques cravate italienne des
chemises inédite et les dernières
exclusivité en vêtements de classe prêt
à porter et sur mesure
jackson vous propose une création pour
les jeunes le mambo jackson boulevard
anspach 157 boulevard adolphe max 70
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs je vous
rappelle que nous sommes en période
électorale et qu'à ce titre en tant qu
émissions du service public
hardy matt et tenus de diffuser des
tribunes libres d'expression électorale
si je les passais pas c'est tout là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si je ne
passais pas il se passerait thierry que
ce serait votre dernière émission vous
retrouveriez speaker remplaçant à télé
barbezieux ouais je crois que j'ai
dépassé alors non c'est vous qui voyez
ouais voici les tribunes libres
l'expression électorale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
odier hu
abattoir réellement les
m
bajnai
il
le bye bye
les toits ap one à menin
[Musique]
oh oh oh bah comme ça tu m
oui elle et vire au mi6 oui c'est à toi
non la logistique pour les vacances vont
rester longtemps peut-être à moi enfin
si j'ai de la chance de la chance tu
cherches quoi je ne sais pas l'homme de
ta vie donc pourquoi pas qui c'est mais
je te conviendrait mois sur ce souvent
des hommes comme ça ah non non non j'ai
encore couché avec personne qui sait
c'est joli ça retient non
[Musique]
oui
mais alors professeur l'audience il a
pas être joli joli là après tout ça non
et dont thierry blancot à l'honnêteté ne
paye pas on nous demande de diffuser de
la politique nous nous diffusons de la
politique résultat nous nous retrouvons
au fond du trou et qui va nous dépanner
maintenant je vous le demande j'ai un
truc gels arme absolue
voici les résultats de notre grand
casting de petits chemins dames et
demoiselles messieurs je vous demande
d'applaudir celles qui ont su séduire la
france les yeux dans les yeux
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il était impossible de
départager stéphanie emmanuel et valérie
nous avons décidé en total accord avec
sophie favier agnès boulard laurange de
sacrée soirée et annie pujol de les
engager toutes les trois pour faire
trois fois plus d'audience
hardy matt a désormais trois fois plus
de petits ça a changé quoi dans ta vie
de passer à la télé tous les samedis
soirs et bien déjà ça m'apporte une
occupation en plus et je suis mieux dans
ma pauvre way sexuellement que ça a
changé quelque chose ou non tout ce
qu'il faut par ailleurs c'est à dire eh
bien ça va ça bien tangible et m
papillon et alba plus son jules il ya
disons que il réfléchit davantage aux
actes tout qui fait aller regarder
il est préoccupé par ce que je fais donc
il se méfie davantage de ski 10 puis
fait plus attention à son attitude il
t'aime plus bas j'espère même j'espère
qu'ils m'aiment plus alors un manuel ça
changeait quoi dans ta vie tu passais
tous les samedis soirs à télévision va 1
contrairement à valérie je suis devenu
célibataire donc vengé oui mais pourquoi
tu as quitté parce qu'il était jaloux
non pas de quoi bassi m'a dit c'est lui
vous tirez un discours donc
rabuffetti éventuelle avancée finit donc
sexuellement ça va beaucoup plus mal
maintenant comment ni pour toi là oui
toi tu vas trouver un autre jules je
sais pas trop de soucis un ça va
je remercie étoiles ans tiffany ça
changeait quoi de passer la télévision
tous les samedis soirs ça a changé tant
de choses par exemple
tout ça tapait dans la rue
[Musique]
dis moi ces familles qui métisse est ce
que tu vis ton métissage comme une forme
d'exclusion
c'est dur y en a beaucoup souffert
lorsque tu étais enfant
oui c'est quand on est petit c'est
vraiment dur à supporter
là bas c'est pas c'est pas chez toi ici
en rejette
finalement c'est quoi ton au lieu de vie
je sais pas j'arrive pas à me retrouver
je me sens pas chez moi nulle pa
est ce que est ce que le regard des gens
te de pez
c'est la solitude toujours
vraiment pas facile
est ce que cette différence et a empêché
trouver un emploi je crois
où
je crois ce que je cherche depuis
longtemps j'étais problème
ce que tu crois que cette double origine
ta interdit vraie histoire d'amour
oui
merci de ta sincérité c'était vraiment
bien merci nous a donné un bon coup de
main pour l'audience
c'est sympa merci c'était fini ok dirige
une petite larme sur stéphanie d'accord
d'accord chanter à la banque mondiale
d'accord on va te mettre une petite
larme c'est pour des plans de coupe tu
sais
ouais bien des larmes bien un parfait la
larme
c'est déchirant fait ouais tu veux pas
ressasser la dernière question avec la
larme chantal non thierry c'est très
bien comme ça devant d'accord on l'a
très bien ma vision tout à l'air
vraiment voilà
mais c'est bien là
ouais c'est bien voilà
ok tu là merci on applaudit à l'occasion
de la sortie du film de claude chabrol
l'oeil de vichy et du pépin de jean
marboeuf et dans notre série les
incidents de plateau jeux n'a jamais
fait de mal à l'audience voici un
document exceptionnel qu'est le double
mérite de dénoncer la collaboration et
de constituer un superbe incidents de
plateau il a raconté des choses qui est
la femme
il a participé à des épreuves démarrent
fait mans je peux vous le souhaitez je
peux vous citer 10 exemple nous avons
incité joueurs oui je vous incite à 2 le
premier y en à témoin qui l'a cette
salle je crois que c'était moi le plus
irréfutable qui existent au monde parce
qu'on n'a rien à [ __ ] dans cette
histoire il s'appelle patrick segal
bon il vous a vu au cambodge mais non il
n'était pas en taule je vous allez
rencontrer auteuil dont vous avez en
tailleur et vous et vous disiez que vous
alliez au cambodge 2 or vous êtes revenu
et d'en match on a vu des photos de
l'effort
or comment êtes vous allé au cambodge
soi disant c'est à dire un taxi dans la
journée à l'évent des guérillas dans la
journée croyez moi écouter alors c'est
arrêter vos attaques je vous réponds
très précisément sur cette histoire
les journalistes qui sont des cours des
ratés départ et salaires
aranha prater et le chauffeur de taxi
avait avec son frère qui commandait une
unité au bord sur la frontière j'ai pu
passer grâce aux chauffeurs de taxi au
cambodge
alors que tous les reporters qui étaient
là étaient boulot quand aranha prat et
nous avons défendu en laye
fonctionnaires on attendant il sert en
attendant d'avoir les avantages ou de
l'espêche salle du sein je suis désolé
ce n'est pas mme samedi dallas ou
simplement qu' il ya eu le malheur des
procès qu'on fait c'est qu'ils ont
toujours des prix 3 cm offrant j'ai
toujours j'ai commis beaucoup plus de
chabrouh mais il croyait pas ce qu'on
reproche à l'evo 3d sur ce point et puis
voilà
là je crois que françois chalais aurait
beaucoup plus de considération pour moi
je lui ai dit mike wargo qui connaît
mariage je suis partout journal
collaborateurs pour savoir les
installations à la libérer
vous avez un jour apple ça ne change
rien si je vends rien alors fini les
seconds c'est en tout cas son dû et ça
compte et ça me rappelle des choses que
j'ai à dire ah bon je croyais tackle
donneront une seconde je voudrais dire
un mot parce que comme ça devient très
grave
ces publicités littérature jeu grand
collaborateur de je suis dans des
chaudières alors désolé alors envie de
danser les juges ouah alors quoi alors
il n'est pas rose avait des preuves
non
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais simplement des choses je vois
que monsieur est d'allier à utiliser les
procédés les plus bas une fois de plus
créé l'événement je croyais qu'ils aient
simplement l'imitateur de châteaubriant
je vois qu'il est celui de thierry le
luron
mais c'est pas fort parce que c'est
ignoble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
aujourd'hui je suis prêt
alors président en ce moment ça oui
c'est pas mal mais enfin vous n'auriez
pas la même chose en plus en plus récent
exemple
c'était samedi dernier sur france 3
gérard de villiers vous habitez avenue
foch le jour a toujours depuis 30 ans à
3 jours un grand appartement
bonjour vous avez une rolls toujours ah
oui toujours
vous avez changé à ce nouveau stage vous
avez des ennuis avec le fisc
j'en ai plus depuis 12 ans ah oui c'est
du tout cuit tout mais vous le
redeviendra juste une seconde oui qu'est
ce que c'est quand même mission c'est
une émission juste une question passé à
rennes leur gouverne attendez-vous avait
invité pour essayer de me démolir ou
pour m'interviewer pour vous qu'on fait
c'est ce qu'on fait ça c'est pour vous
qu'on fait ça ce sont des questions
nettement agressive alors si moi j'ai
rien à faire ici on en reste là
[Musique]
alors moi j'aime bien les amis la
télévision je vous aime bien venir à une
émission se faire attaquer non seulement
ces deux amis
non là là là vous n'êtes pas changé bon
je crois que je pense bon je prends d'un
jeu ouvert sa porte et méchant qui sort
il vient faire sa promo à la télé quoi
de plus normal voici patrick chesnais
et
[Musique]
on
c'est là qu'est ce qui va chez valve ya
un truc sur ce plateau qui est un peu le
bizarre je n'ai pas qu'il arrive ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière avec
princess erika ouais ce qui s'est passé
je sais pas je crois je vais faire un
contrôle anti corti tuquoi antilles
qu'en fit connaît pas parce que les
missions non je parle aux chiens ap
venise vrai mafieux chesnais n'a pas vu
les émissions précédentes idées comme
quelques-uns de mes adhérents donc à ce
moment-là envoyer un petit résumé des
épisodes précédents
peut-être on va alors résumé des
ça assez kerry forcément thierry
l'animateur
il anime c'est pas simple thierry
l'animateur conseil
et là c'est le professeur rollin
professeur pourquoi pourquoi pas en face
à l'iran 93 c'est forcément troll
lui c'est le président laura 18 millions
d'adhérents
étrange tous ces gens qu'il aime
forcément comme tous les présidents
et voilà les amis de l'animateur ils
appellent ça la jet set
le monde a changé c'est la télévision
c'est l'europe
ce sont des amis et lui c'est corti il
veut passer à la télé salle fascine la
télé l'appelle et lui parle
et puis il ya ces filles elles sont
jolies elles sont jeunes
ce sont de jolies jeunes filles il les
appelle les télés potiche alors voilà
l'émission s'appelle hardy matt et puis
il ya ce chien et eux ils le menacent et
c'est peut-être aussi ça la télé corti
le score
cortina score non mon avis avec corti le
score vous n'arriverez à rien il est
verrouillé là dessus pour le début ce
qu'il faut faire qu'est-ce qu'on écoute
corti qu'est ce qu'un écho de corti
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corte quelle
journée
excuse moi à tenir qu'est ce que les
coûts de corte qu'est ce que les quotes
parts et
qu'est ce que ça a l'air normal ça a
l'air normal
qu'est ce qu'on est qu'est-ce qu'on
écoute corti non excusez-moi excuse moi
je prends prod je contrôle je contrôle
roy professeur salaire normal
j'ai l'impression je ne pense pas qu'ils
puissent résister avec lui faut se
méfier avec un petit peu parce qu'il est
capable de se planquer partout hein
il est capable de tout ouais il est
capable de tout moment à commencer
l'interview promo classique ton film
s'appelle drôle d'oiseau
ouais ça fils de qui ce film de peter
kassovitz potiche dit bonjour monsieur
est un film de peter kassovitz way avec
giraudeau et bunge gerdau tuque et aux
gâteaux
isabelle gélinas et toi c'est quoi
l'histoire c'est une histoire de son
histoire de moeurs khl
drôle c'est une chose de comédie jeudi
du mur noir où les gens se tuent enfin
en tout cas deux ambitions de mon
désordre le meurtre et
voilà donc ce traité sur le mode de la
cannelle jackson comme ils disent rien
que avec un certain suspense une en rit
beaucoup
même si on aurait pu t'en rôle c'est
quoi c'est un flic fatigué c'est à dire
que c'était un flic de province qu'il
arrive 37 meurtres sur le temps de cette
cadavre sur les bras et puis tombe
amoureux ce qui fait beaucoup pour un
seul homme ça se passe en quelques jours
un gars sont fatigués qui essaie de s'en
sortir et
kim qui fait et qui par là même arrive à
faire rire mais tu veux c'est qu'on
regarde un extrait là je veux bien
regarder un extrait à mâcher le vendre
merci d'être venus si vick d'abord g g
ii nouvellement commencer par l'abonné
elles sont toutes les deux mauvaises
à commencer par la plus mauvaise et que
je vous dise alors d'abord nous avons
retrouvé les clés de ma clio dans les
débris les supermarchés race est ce une
bonne nouvelle c'est plus que j'ai
balancé ma femme on est aux fourneaux
non par contre je me demande comment les
clés ont pu atterrir ici derrière une
porte coupe feu dans un endroit
inaccessible au public
voilà alors ça c'est la mauvaise
mauvaise nouvelle c'est là les tap-taps
je me dis mon assistante a énormément
d'imagination on accord mais recule pas
je vais tout vous dire je vous écoute
vous écoute
elle m'a annoncé sa un soir de déprime
d'abord j'ai pas que j'ai pensé tout
simplement qu a voulu me faire de la
plaine m tromper que ce type de type
quel type un homme qui travaille aux
jeunes j'ai pas cherché à en savoir plus
vous ne mourrez a pensé pour un savon à
barbe tant pis allez monsieur l'on nous
ait quelque chose malheur est bon
traduction traduction vous avez une bête
de cocu rappeler aux médias en assistant
ne veut dire simplement que sa fille
était de votre épouse ont dû mieux gérer
votre permis d'inhumer merci monsieur
commission d'après imagine que tu es une
minute pour nous envoyer voir ce film
drôle d'oiseau tu dirais quoi eh ben je
dirais qu'il faut qu'ils font elle voir
parce que d'abord je suis dedans
ce qui n'est pas tout les engins ce qui
peut être une bonne raison
[Musique]
tu as quel âge peutrec
j'ai un truc 44-46 ses souvenirs
je commence la souffre il ya trois
quatre ans de vieillissement et 84 ans
maintenant tu apprends révolue tu le vis
mal c'est vieillissement je me suis
habitué
au début ça a été un peu dure a pu tout
à petit on s'y habitue
et puis je pense qu'on vieillit mesure
mieux la mort
quel âge tu peux rencontrer pour la
première fois la mort
et j'ai un contrat demain je vais 30 ans
explications personne proche c'était mon
beau-frère savalas d'accord sur une
larme pour des plantes
oui bien sûr j'entends bien sûr non
beau-frère s'affermir oui peut plus se
voir mais une petite larme
ça marche très très bien dans les
reality show les petites larmes voilà
très bien la chantal alarme bombe et
c'est très bien ainsi une bonne lame
l'arn de bio bon et patrick merci donc
on ira tous voir un drôle d'oiseau de
peter kassovitz merci beaucoup
bertry
[Applaudissements]
vous avez été des dizaines de milliers à
nous écrire pour vous étonnez injuste
tirent de l'absence de jeu dans une
émission qui se bat pour faire de
l'audience
et vous avez raison alors toute l'équipe
d'art dit matt a imaginé pour vous le
concept de chercher l'intrus
regardez attentivement les quatre
chanteurs suivant et cherchez l'intrus
m
là
[Musique]
bienvenue
je sais
à la vie
à des scores de ses quais
adecco
le cei alors
ennemi
papa
[Musique]
oh
ap
[Musique]
m
emma
[Musique]
elle
pareil au même
gioia
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous jouez président lorrain cherchez
l'intrus a c'est moi qui aie
ouais c'est vous oh là bas je dirais
peut-être c'est peut-être c'est gilbert
montagné oui c'est gilbert montagné
parce que ces sales blancs non mais vous
avez droit à une seconde chance avant
c'est sammy davis junior parce qu'il est
le seul borgne n'a comme ça non mais
vous avez droit à une troisième chance
oh là là là c'est ses fins et les durs à
oui c'est dur c'est très serré de
charges si red shirt parce que c'est le
seul qui a une veste argentée à motifs
tout ça non alors la profession là notre
président bien aimé n'est pas tombé loin
avec eux quatre tentatives il aurait
sûrement trouver la bonne réponse qui
était steevy vander car c'est le seul à
porter le nom d'une pile
[Applaudissements]
président je suis absolument désolé
vraiment mais n'était pas loin si
j'étais pas loin c'est très très fort
cherchez l'intrus est très très fort
bravo ce jeu cherchez l'intrus est
magnifique alors je serai bon perdant
car comme l'a si bien dit julien lepers
l'important c'est de participer mais
vous dire monsieur ardisson ça me fait
très plaisir et je suis sûr que ça fera
très plaisir hein mais 18 millions
d'adhérents le fait qu'ils aient des
jeux qui reviennent le jeu intelligent
subtil comme celui là car sera conduit
l'a annoncé c'est pas con c'est subtil
c'est très fin et prado ça me rappelle
la très très belle époque de la
télévision où il y avait des beaux jeux
comme ça des variétés inventive avec des
balles et des décors l'école début de
chemin en un mot et chaumont l'école des
buttes chaumont et et à ce propos là
monsieur ardisson de mme aviez promis il
ya quelques temps déjà de recevoir dans
votre émission marité gilbert carpentier
je ne les vois pas je le redis je n'ai
jamais promis président assis j'avoue il
demande pardon on me l'avait promis
l'autre jour quand on est sortis jamais
you no more avait promis un café que
vous m'avez offert le café mais vous ne
m'aviez en même tant promis les
carpentier que je ne vois pas alors là
mais promis mais les voilà quand même ma
rétine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
en haïti j'ai eu affaire dentier bonsoir
ça alors le président lorrain parler de
l'école des buttes chaumont est ce que
ça existe l'école des buttes chaumont
oui d'une certaine façon je pense que
les décors des buttes chaumont c'était
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
ça le sera encore si on devait d
émission oui y en a un petit peu moi
mais bon un peu moins oui c était quoi
vos plus grandes émissions à tous les
deux ça la grande farandole
numéro 1 les tops et puis d'étape show
différent avec roger pierre et jean marc
thibault vu deux sur l'a2 devine qui est
derrière la porte 20 pour l'instant il y
en a à peu près 675 en stock à li na
oui d'ailleurs quand vous regardez les
ventes n avait pas de problème d'image
oui et quand vous regardez en effet les
antennes
vous voyez beaucoup de nos extraits oui
certaines passaient par extraits
maintenant c'est à dire que maintenant
quand on vous dit qu'est ce que vous
faites et bien on est dans nos télés on
regarde nos extraits chez les autres oui
vous savez a tenté quoi la télévision
vous voyez on apporte et peut-être que
qu'on a un peu un petit peu enlevé le
côté guindé de consommer dans vos sorts
une demoiselle nous c'était jean yanne
c'était pouvoir essaie de nay ans qui
présentait en se moquant de leurs
copains ou c'était sardou eddy mitchell
tout ce qu'ils se taillader enfin sera
bref non mais j'ai des petites
difficultés d'élocution et donc c'était
ce côté là c'était démystifier un peu
tout ça donne et de l'humour à ton et
puis du glamour souvent pensé quoi la tv
d'aujourd'hui
moi je la trouve pas chic si vous avez
une petite surprise
josé puisqu'ils avaient paré un petit
une petite chanson all voilà pour vous
pour vous rendre hommage car angers j'ai
été bercé toute mon enfance toute ma
jeunesse par les numéros un les tops pas
aller tout sera une sorte de l'univers
dans votre garde une petite inquiétude
ah non non non non vous n'avez rien à
craindre en bois bien sûr c'est un petit
peu amateur on a fait ça assez
rapidement on n'a pas les décors
magnifiques que vous aviez à chaque fois
pour chaque chanson il y avait un décor
ça c'est extraordinaire
alors cette chanson plus est là pour moi
une signification c'est comme les rois
mages de sheila et dans la chanson les
diamants suis ton étoile il faut suivre
son étoile et je suis sûr que quelque
part il ya une bonne étoile qui vous
attend vous aussi vous non ah non pas
tout de suite non non mais sept étoiles
si vous la suivez elle va vous ramener
la sfp comme les rois mages en galilée
suis fait des yeux l'étoile du berger
je te suivrai où tu iras j'irai fidèles
comme une ombre
jusqu'à destination comme l'hérault
mages en galilée
suivez des yeux l'étoile du berger comme
christophe colomb et ses trois
caravelles ont suivi le soleil jusqu'à
destination plaise au ciel que s'ouvre
mes fenêtres le matin au bord d'un étang
bleus
plaise au ciel que rien ne nous arrête
dans ce monde aventure
comme les rois mages en galilée suis
fait des yeux l'étoile du berger mon
amérique
ma vérité cosmique ma lumière biblique
c'est de vivre avec toi
alerte enfin un peu quand même c'est
l'émotion
les motifs à la marée qui et gilbert
carpentier je vais apprécier l'hommage
que vous a rendu le prénom justement est
ce que je vais te regarder dans le fond
des yeux thierry oui oui est ce que pour
vous pour toi nous sommes ça non bon
d'accord parce que vous c'est vachement
mieux non mais parce que alors trouve en
nous on a l'impression que pour la vie
entière
on est maqué on est marié avec etc ont
fêté avec le strass avec mistinguett et
ça on a bon cela dit what a été
formidable si mais c'est un peu comme
toi avec le sexe quand j'entends que
c'est alors que j'ai pu le droit d'en
parler en fait c'est pour toi ça doit
être très douloureux compte et surtout
que j'ai pu voir m a encore le droit de
faire des confettis moi j'ai plus droite
par les deux sexes voilà c'est notre
mais enfin bon c'était un hommage comme
ça ils ont échangé aux adhérents ouais
c'est bien pris mais je voulais préciser
trader est tout de même on a emmené jane
dans les égouts tout va pour faire une
émission contre l'irlande on ya eu
l'irlande où il a eu bien eu beaucoup
d'endroits très crade
on a beau me confie t on les abandonnait
ya une bonne quinzaine d'années comme un
merci marie thé gilbert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici votre quatrième invité de la
soirée tom selleck
vous avez été des centaines de milliers
à nous écrire pour exiger du sport dans
des maps comme toujours dans cette
émission nous répondrons à vos attentes
mais vous le savez la disparition de la
publicité sur le tabac et la pression du
lobby écologiste ont obligé la fille zae
le président balestre à trouver une
riposte en exclusivité dans l'art d'imad
et avec la complicité du service des
sports de france 2 voici les images des
essais secrets qui ont lieu actuellement
sur les plus grands circuits du monde
pour remplacer la formule
[Musique]
mon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
elles se disent qu'elle vient faire sa
promo à la télé tout ça est parfaitement
normal voici notre cinquième invité
gloria lasso
[Musique]
rien à son bon soir quand est ce que tu
as fait l'amour pour la première pour la
dernière fois le ton accent gloria tu le
fais exprès comme comme jane birkin ou
c'est naturel et le titre de temps en
album c'est bien come back de admin
c'est ça ouais ça va non non non non non
non excusez moi non non pas du tout est
ce que tu fais là
comment est ce que je fais là elle
regarde ton papier te verra ce que je
fais mais qua non je fais une interview
de de bois de ficelles c'est un groupe
de country c'est quoi cette histoire web
ficelles ces marabouts et suzette c'est
un groupe de country très connus whitney
mais si c'est pourtant maintenant que tu
es la régalade ouest c'est vraiment ait
affiché est ce que tu dis là
bon ben alors quand maryse qu'est-ce qui
m'a mis les fiches de gloria lasso dans
l'interview de boîtes ficelles la
rescousse cuse moins je sais pas bon ben
écoute mais toi là on va parler de ton
disque est ouest ça c'est une bonne idée
tu vois jarry
voilà une bonne chaise jolie formidable
soit on n'aura qu'à interviewé bois de
ficelle la fois à boîte ficelles la
semaine prochaine alors gloria bonsoir
soir donc tu vient de ressortir toutes
les tubes c'est un engin il ya aussi des
chansons nouvelles
ah bon ouais ouais ya des chansons
nouvelles c'est avant tout la musica et
puis très deux intellectuels et puis
c'est ma vie ça c'est joli sinon il y a
il y a godelier bambino bon voyage gna
gna gna gna gna gna
pourquoi tu le disais tous enregistrés
tous et tous ces morceaux est pas
ressorti des versions de l'époque non
c'est parce que le public le réclame les
versions de l'époque sont chez une autre
maison de disque et on n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord avec leur connerie qui
font tout le temps complet alors bon on
a dit bon débarras faire ça parce que
vous pas lui donner un petit peu de
fraîcheur mais sait-on souviennent ses
chansons de l'époque n'a rien su pour un
voyage par exemple c'était comment c'est
pas la peine avait plein de cette triste
mais qui tombe puisque c'est elle et qui
t'aime tu attends mon voyage voyage pas
tout à fait le bien fallu bien pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
bon voyage et à l'évasion part en voyage
tu vois par exemple quand j'écoute la
régie social il ya avant-hier oui et
bien sûr je fais et bon voyage
je tombe ça q q mais alors c'est vrai
qu'on a mais surtout évacuer alors s'il
vaut mieux faire un bon voyage
mais c'est plus la mélodie voyage tu
fais deux fois à tendresse pour moi
garde là ça fait plein matin je suis et
en algérie si ça c'est joli mannequin à
temps perdu dans le pays plus étrangère
au paradis ça c'est joli parce que la
musique c'est une musique de dub rudin
donc c'est pas n'importe qui
et là les paroles sur de francis blanche
non c'était vraiment une très jolie
ensemble et genius ça a donné un énorme
succès venus à vénus j'adore cette
chanson venus mon ami est malade la nuit
je vous en prie envoyez moi l'amour dont
j'ai rêvé
il est temps de les lire
d
voyez sur mon lit toujours le lithgow -
faut qu'il ya 18 ans et le mariage pour
finir tu en es aux pages est attendait
non c'est juste une petite question
comme ça foster mariage mais écoute tu
sais je suis très difficile oui je
n'allais pas l'air mais pour le mariage
il faut beaucoup de choses je suis très
romantique
il me faut l'eau le bord de l'eau les
palmiers le clair de lune comme face des
patients comme le disent des poésies
exemple comme écrit des lettres d'amour
comme en bois des bonbons et chocolat
tout ça c'est non c'est non on n'y
arrivera pas ce soir par contre oui
c'est qu'ils absolument merveilleux
c'est qu'une fois qu'on est marié et
tombera
là ça va comme sur des roulettes je lui
apprends tout de suite à faire le saut
du lustre
tu connais nous sommes une vieille
nation fait ça tous les soirs voilà
départ des lustres du thé valence comme
ça c'est excitant devait pas savoir
comme ça après tu te laisses tomber tu
te casses la gueule
et alors là c'est le comble moi ça ne
comble au delà de l'excitation chez moi
thierry mais je trouve touchant
extrêmement coucou oui tu trouves quoi
les coûts du lustre avec nous parce que
tu n'as pas essayer de faire coucou je
suis professeur voilà c'est non non mais
pas fait saine mais regarde la tête
qu'il a il peut tu peux pas faire toi le
lustre je peux le faire nager dans les
looks le sait c'est une élite du mont
blanc
c'est une immersion des bleus dit
rendez-vous dans son vin
on
et
veille au soir
[Applaudissements]
alors
thierry tout allait très bien jusqu'à ce
que vous vous mettiez à chanter venus
mon ami comme aurélien c'est
l'effondrement absolue je le crois pas
je m'en fous j'ai une arme absolue
on ne dit pas je m'en fous dire oui à
realp à venise on dit je m'en moque je
m'en moque
jack nicholson dans au fait nous allons
nous mettre nous allons nous servir
chercher
il était capable de tout ce que je dis
c'est qu'on peut obtenir beaucoup plus
c'est normal c'est juste ça nous est dû
il c'est possible il n'avait peur de
personne il peut vous coincé dans une
impasse et vous tabasser jusqu'à ce que
vous supplier truc tu es et lui qu'il
m'offre un café et je répondre à ces
questions
c'est pourquoi tout le monde avait peur
de lui la justice pourrait vous demander
des comptes monsieur enfin vous ne
m'intimide pas j'ai pas besoin 300
millions de dollars et d'un frère
président pour vous botter le cul
il narguait la loi est là mon geste et
fait ce qu'il faut pour qu'elle savait
qu'elle soit moi ah oui et comment je
fais tout ce qu'il faut faire
les victimes il y en a dans tous les
conflits la seule question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on a perdu et qu'est-ce
qu'on a gagné
[Musique]
twenty century fox présente un film de
danny devito un jour ce type sera
président des états unis jack nicholson
comptez acheter les flics ça c'est
facile
un jour c'est les gangsters que j'achète
danny devito vous pourriez changer de
camp et témoigner contre lui
vous voulez que je fasse tomber jimmy
hoffa
[Musique]
ça
isidore oui oui c'est de gamme vous
n'auriez pas la même chose en plus pas
de problème président suffit de demander
dans le genre de scénario catastrophe
c'était pas mal non plus chez nous en
juillet dernier on avait même dans le
rôle de nicholson tarzan titi routier
bien de chez nous star des médias béret
l'avait invitée pour discuter le bout de
gras
ce fut une grosse production avec gros
moyens et nombreux figurants pour les
dialogues interdit de donner du tar gz
en mai du jeu les faits c'était notre
jimmy hoffa à nous voilà sauf que huit
mois plus tard patatras
mon patron m'a pas digéré la la note bon
alors ben badis ans et il était capable
de tout si on est balèze déconne arrière
dans sa tête ça sert absolument à rien
ce que je dis c'est qu'il peut obtenir
plus c'est normal c'est juste ça nos
études
moi je continue à je continue à essayer
que tout soit tout soit fait ce qu'on
voulait en juillet quoi et les
employeurs attendent maintenant tarzan
avec un bazooka histoire de perdre
quelques grammes dit-il daniel l'éphèbe
à la campagne et le rappelle des
souvenirs
c'est à dire un bon se voir à la
télévision tous à être reconnue dans les
dans les rues tout ça c'est vrai que ça
fait plaisir
il y en a dans tous les conflits la
seule question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a
perdu et qu'est-ce qu'on a gagné
je sais j'ai grillé
pas grand chose
c'est à dire que
j'ai gagné j'ai rien gagné est ce que le
plus intelligent en fait c'est celui qui
a pas pris de risque dont celui qui a
pris des risques je pose la question
[Musique]
vous le savez peut-être nombreuses
émissions de télévision françaises sont
en fait des adaptations de succès
étrangers citant au hasard la roue de la
fortune qui vient des états unis
que le meilleur gagne qui nous arrive
d'australie toute la ville en parle qui
est allemand des nouveaux qui sont
canadiens ou salut les artistes qui est
importé de grande bretagne
mais l'émission à succès de tf1
méfiez-vous des blondes présenté par un
travesti est inspiré de dames edna un
concept américain
amanda lear n'aurait donc vient
d'inventer la preuve en images
exclusivité hardy matt jamais autant de
stars longtemps filakio portée d'un talk
show américain aussi qu est ambiguë que
ce présentateur
à l'époque je peux toucher top petit
bras là mon petit bâtiment je n'ai
toujours pas été perturbé thomas il
n'est pas parti il est même très gros
combat là un tupperware je voudrais
touché leurs plus gros lot et organes
[Applaudissements]
cette drôle de dame est en fait un mal
australiens avec une femme et quatre
enfants en l'atalaye l'affairé à ce
vraiment et pas sa patte immeuble 7 paul
minot en troquant son sexe fort contre
le sexe faible dame edna a fait bondir
l'audimat australiens anglais puis
américain aujourd'hui son rêve avoué
fricoter avec le pouvoir politique
la coquine
[Musique]
j'adore recevoir il avait dans mon
émission lier barbara bush m'a envoyé
une lettre
se pliant de l'inviter à si elle décide
de faire un régime
peut-être quand je dirais oui
alors un film qui sort elle vient faire
sa promo à la télé tout ça est
parfaitement normal voici notre sixième
invité laurence treille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors donc tu as la fiche dans un film
de max fischer qui s'appelle les veufs
pourquoi tu le dis ce sont les enfants
les veuves avec l'attendrir c'est quoi
l'histoire histoire c'est un petit peu
compliqué j'ai pas te la raconter tout
de suite parce que c'est assez long donc
ce sens ne m'a donc fait un film
donc ça dure 1h30 40 c'est un policier
et cinq aux lardons
il ya beaucoup de scénarii gacé
hitchcockienne puisque c'est le dernier
scénario quichotte vous la mettre en
scène avant sa mort donc c'est pas mal
ce un bon nicolas l'ex fischer tu peux
lui parler de lui max fischer il est il
est canadien d'origine égyptienne
c'est un c'est un homme très brillant
qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup de choses
dans sa vie beaucoup producteurs de
martin scorsese d'afida été dans l'art
dans la peinture n'ont rien fait
beaucoup de choses vraiment ça serait ça
sera aussi pareil pour résumer c'est
très difficile tu veux qu'on voit un
extrait ah oui c'est bien bon moment
regardez un extrait une bagnole je pense
qu'encore aventure je travaille avec lui
et lui avec marc je te cacher quelque
chose
j'étais avec marc vous à une séance de
photos dans grand secret et là je peux
te dire parce que le contrat quel
contrat
par contre à la con una qu'une ridicule
petit clown dans laquelle on
m'interdisait d'en parler à qui que ce
soit et ni même à toi mais en fait si je
ne t'ai rien dit ce n'est pas parce que
je n'avais pas le temps c'est parce que
ces gens là me donne l occasion de
s'offrir un cadeau que je rejette de fer
depuis le jour de notre de notre
première rencontre arrête moi cette
vignette qui sont ces gens tu te
rappelles cette partie la galerie marc
m'a dit qu'on m'avait choisi le produit
était à une nouvelle marque de parfums
top secret ça devait payer petite
fortune c'est pour de grandes années à
vivre sans souci doit écrire moi tu
regardais le magic était une minute pour
nous vendre ce film pourquoi n'y a et de
voir les salles de cinéma je dirais quoi
très très présentes creusement gyr est
allé le voir parce que je suis dedans
bien sûr tu as créé mois sinon quoi
d'autre
je ne suis pas encore très habillée dans
le film je pense que certains vont me le
reprocher mais c'est comme l'histoire du
scorpion et de la grenouille tu sais ça
doit être dans ma nature de me balader à
poil donc sur le voir à poil on va voir
le fidèle exactement à envoyer du monde
en disant c'est vrai c'est vraiment la
meilleure valeur volatile a fait bien là
pouvoir user et puis j'y suis je suis
bien filmé tenue toute nue non non non
on va on va arrêter de patte de dos
pendant encore 20 secondes tu dirais
quoi encore avoué pour vendre ton fils
pour mon film
c'est entre nicolas schmit en jeu 10 à
30 jours et j'ai fait des mammifères dix
ans il ya un petit problème c'est que ça
fait deux fois j'ai pas voulu dire tout
à l'heure mais que le professeur rollin
chante c'est aujourd'hui dimanche et
j'ai peur que cela induit âmes qui peut
les téléspectateurs en erreur car
aujourd'hui nous sommes samedi
oui mais on est samedi - lens
quand tu étais petit
j'étais grande des jeux wii c'est à dire
que je n'ai pas eu la chance de pouvoir
dire aux petits garçons qui m'embêtait
tuer raconte soigante parce que je
l'étais déjà donc forcément chez
impressionné le regard des autres sur
toi c'était c'est traumatisant wef
regard des autres sur moi fin quand il
arrivait à m'atteindre bien sûr parce
que j'étais perdue dans les dents les
auteurs un peu temps beaucoup plus
millions non non non pas une mini ans
palmor dans ces cas-là on veut s'en
sortir à tout prix tu sais quoi
c'est un peu tout fait 1 je souhaiterais
vraiment je serai pas remuer ce serait
pas muet de tous et toutes là c'est moi
manger j'ai tout fait mais quel a été le
moyen pour toi de de fuir ce corps qui
est emprisonné
c'est fait des conneries bon comme comme
tous les jeunes femmes je regrette un
petit peu mais c'est le passé cette
beauté que tu revendiques c'est une
thune vengeance contre toi même contre
les autres non franchement j'ai à moi
même si non mais ça va ça va un
professeur un serment t c'est génial et
les oui oui bien sur wii la maquilleuse
oui oui on a besoin de tout ça on a
besoin de petites larmes des fois pour
des plans de cours voilà chantal tu fais
tes gros plans de larmes là tu les as la
merci de ta sincérité laurence ça t'a
fait du bien nous parler en bien alors
tu es ici pour parler de son dernier
film sur balles et du premier vite elle
veut qu'on le revoilà wesh bien et c'est
marrant ça fait pas mal de temps en
avant qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à être
en forme et qu'est ce que j'ai je suis
pas aux normes
[Musique]
il faut que tu te traînes yfrog prône
pouces super comme qu'est ce qu'ils ont
tous
[Musique]
ils sont tous à sauter en l'air mois
dans tout ça qu'est-ce que je peux faire
il faut que j'élimine bikaï vous aide à
retrouver jacques canetti qui est enfoui
tu peux nous parler du tournage c'était
dur de vittel ouais c'était très très
dure cinq jours cinq jours sur la
pelouse a dit elle donc invité là-bas
vélo golf piscine thalasso très dur
payer employés en plus on a été obligé
de boire beaucoup pour entrer dans la
peau du personnage
1 beaucoup d'eau mais beaucoup d'eau
était arrêtée après tu es arrivé à
parité et beaucoup de prises pour le
film non parce que je faisait le pitre
assez facilement fait pas m'en demander
beaucoup de gens n'a un autre qui a
beaucoup ramer pour tourner son film
d'eau minérale tu vas voir regarde
ceinture 36 premières ça va tirer d'un
tiers 36 2e
parfait
sabathia et non à 10h36 troisième bac
ça va terry enfin sur 36 4e
ça va terry
[Musique]
saint pierre
fap
ça va être très fort alors ans mercy en
irak us voir les veuves de max fischer
au cinéma grâce à toi oui excusez moi y
est je suis assez content d'avoir vu ces
images de patrick sabatier car nous
sommes le 13 qui est un jour de chance
nous n'avons toujours pas de nouvelles
patrick sabatier qui lui arrive avec son
concept sur tf1 monsieur mougeotte ne
m'a pas appelé il ne vous a pas fait non
plus alors la nouvelle devrait vous
rappeler que patrick sabatier a sorti un
très beau livre qui s'appelle le livre
de la chance qui est son plus beau livre
livre la chance 87
comme quoi patrick savatier n'est pas un
homme rancunier alors acheter tout ce
livre est à bientôt patrick sabatier de
même monsieur ardisson vous m'aviez
promis des nouvelles de gillette ao je
suis pas arrivé j'ai laissé quatre
messages chez elle m'a jamais rappelé
d'ailleurs si gillett a au montant
qu'elle m'appelle j'y l'efs appelle moi
ça m'aidera pour les 18 millions de
téléspectateurs du président laurent
wolf avait tiré une personne qui d'un
seul coup je salue je sais c'est
embêtant
je sais je sais on salue lance très et
merci laurent
vous avez été des millions à nous écrire
pour nous parler de ça beaucoup d'entre
vous se sont émus de son sort dans
l'hypothèse où l'audience dardy matt
descendrait en dessous de 15% mais peut
en revanche savent ce qu'ils arrivent à
zap les semaines où l'émission a bien
marché
voici un reportage tourné samedi dernier
sur la vie heureuse d'un chien
d'audience récompensés grâce à vous
[Musique]
m on a décidé une très bonne soirée de
gala
tu veux retirer aussi d'ailleurs mis sur
la fusion michaud
[Musique]
moi
c'est un très beau temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
oui
le crtc
m
[Musique]
thierry quel beau souvenir c'est ce que
c'est ça non un papier
la note de chez michou samedi dernier on
a payé consommation 43 1831 francs au
repas 22 1179 entre divers 807 francs
total 61 1500 francs dont tva
douze mille 300 francs avec nos
remerciements à ceux qui disent qu'on
n'aime pas ce connard d'athlètes ce
matin cancer se voir deux personnes
professeurs oui eh bien mon cher thierry
compte tenu de ce que ce charmant petit
chien nous coûte il serait fortement
nécessaire de regonfler l'audience parce
que sinon nous n'allons pas pouvoir
assurer vingt dix les jeunes g l'armé
absolue professeurs mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs voici un très
beau numéro dire que ce sont des
amateurs en pis les acrobates
[Musique]
oui
je crois tiré que ce sujet ne trompe
personne ne nous avait présenté ses
acrobates comme des amateurs
il est patent à l'image que ce sont des
professionnels et nos professeurs ce
sont des acrobates a maintenant vous
assure sur sur y est je vous assure j'ai
rien dit là le banc après les jeux du
cirque voici les jeux du sexe le pénis
doit être en érection pour pouvoir
entrer dans le vagin
[Musique]
la première fois qu'une fille fait
l'amour la fine membrane qui voit
l'entrée de son vagin se déchire au
passage du pénis du garçon mais la
douceur et la tendresse sont
généralement que tout se passe bien
10 il n'est pas facile de faire pour la
première fois ce que l'on ne connaît pas
l'amour aussi
c'est une chose qui se découvrent qu'ils
explorent souvent pendant des années
quand on fait l'amour
il y a des sensations de plaisir plus
forte que d'autres
l'excitation sexuelle du garçon augmente
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient l'impression
qu'il ne peut plus se retenir et le
sperme jaillit du bout de son pénis
c'est l'éjaculation pour la fille
le moment d'excitation maximum coïncide
avec une série d' onde de plaisir qui
envahissent tout son être
et puis les corps s'apaisent se
détendent et chacun savoure son
bien-être
et celui des nôtres mais ça marche et
non écoutés thiery je ne sais pas si
c'est le sujet qui n'a pas plu ou si
c'est le fameux effet frigo en tout cas
une nouvelle fois pour parler comme les
jeunes l'audience est en chute libre
avant chute libre j'ai tenté une sortie
alors véronique sanson zénith à monsieur
ardisson oui vous m'aviez promis que
vous maîtrisez parce qu'il n'attaquera
pour la petite valise en plus vous savez
quoi on va chanter dans la manu tu viens
franck tu viens
[Musique]
m minuit hne
mais dépêche toi toi on va la rate et
les sorties de scène il va sortir de
scène mais tu connais pas paris c'est
pas possible
allez on quitte a dit arrêté au feu
rouge
qui va trouver sa place
attention
mais sinon c'est pas les dîners d'axa
pour le zénith mais son centre est
ressorti d'aller vers le 9e round je
m'en fous elle va être sans kit scène
chanson oh la la
lorsqu'il au score
et
jean
mais allez on n'a jamais mis arrivé le
matin on va pas voir le match à sa
session pendant 500 ans et plus et c'est
bien mais bon on est la verdure où on
est on va jamais y arriver la ville est
fait pas par là
pas du tout non là on est à neuilly
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corti véronique
sanson rien que de l'eau
philippe mais qu'est ce qui vous a
planté là maintenant je t'avais dit
qu'ils avaient rien pour toi dans
l'émission j'ai maintenant on regarde
journée véronique sanson josemi tu nous
as et là je dois 20 ans à casse toi je
crois pas ça regarde nous appelons tu
ailles pas reconnue et dont il pas parti
avec les clés d'un tir bas sont ils
partis avec les grilles et votre permis
mais non de façon me l'enlever ya trois
semaines et vous j'ai jamais eu
[Musique]
pas
ces votes sur moi qui vous a poussé à
devenir président je crois oui si c'est
pas si ça a été très conscient chez moi
tout de suite mais je me suis sentie
pousser il fallait qu'il fallait que ça
se fasse il fallait fallait que je
devienne président à tout prix j'ai un
peu l'impression que que c'était écrit
je devais être président président de
quoi je sais pas tout cas je devais être
un président ça c'est sûr inconsciemment
jeunesse a été vécue si hocine et
l'obéissance islemère omniprésente mère
omniprésente un père très
très autoritaire très très dur très
castratrice
mère castratrice et et un père qui
commande qui lui-même vivent une
castration de la part de son épouse
reporter sur moi une espèce de violence
d'agressivité je crois que vous venger
d'une adolescence provincial en
terrorisant des examinateurs l'otv grand
palais oui en même temps vous savez j'ai
pas j'ai pas envie de vous terroriser
jeu si ça se passe c'est que c'est c'est
comme ça il fallait chez exerce ce
pouvoir là si sur quelques à la télé
j'aurais pu devenir peut-être si j'avais
eu du talent metteur en scène
vous occultez l'absence du c'est ça
une issue
ce culte à la fois cette absence qui qui
ne pouvait que qu'éclater avec cette
présence trop forte pourrait que diop
était homosexuel
je crois que
je crois qu et deep a été lui aussi un
garçon malheureux garçon perdu
je crois que deep
frey vous voyez qu'il couchait avec ça
j'ai une bonne et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux